now i know from experience that at times
you can feel as if you're not making any
progress you feel you've put a lot of
effort into it you've been reading and
listening perhaps more than once
reviewing your words and you still
forget them and you still can't make
sense of what you're reading or
listening to that's normal however
in order to make sure you stay positive
which is so important you'll remember
the three keys attitude is so important
we have a lot of statistics that link
which show you that even though at times
you feel you're not moving very quickly
if you see how many words you've saved
how many words you've read the various
statistics uh learn words learned and so
forth refer to them from time to time
because it's very important to stay
positive there are moments when you all
of a sudden say wow you know a month ago
i couldn't make sense of this and now
it's clear to me but there are other
times when you feel as if you're not
getting anywhere and that's where it's
so important to stay positive and check
against your goals and see just how much
you actually have achieved